[Musique]
joyeux noël à tous j'espère vous avez
été gâtés que le père noël est passé
chez vous et puis vous emmener plein de
cadeaux or si les papas sait pas qu'il
aille se faire
en tout cas je te les moi
personnellement vous souhaiter un joyeux
noël à espérer que vous êtes tous très
heureux en famille entre amis je vous
souhaite beaucoup de bonheur
je vous souhaite beaucoup de joie je
tenais à vous le dire parce que ces
petits moments là qui sont importants
pour qu'on reste un petit peu dans cette
petite confidence ce petit cocon qui
nous appartient cac avouer qu'à moi je
vous souhaite de passer de très bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année alors on passerait
d'une rétrospective tout de suite de
l'année 2017
en attendant j'étais très heureux car
cette année avec vous parce que tu
commencé fin 2016 sans ma chaîne youtube
vraiment en travaillant en améliorant
contenu on essaiera d'aller plus loin
par des choses qui vous intéressait
davantage
voilà il a fallu du temps et les choses
se sont fait tout doucement aujourd'hui
je suis content parce qu on a quand même
un truc qui qui qui qui lui plaire moi
je pense qu'il vous plaît aussi à vous
qui a regardé en face parce que vous me
le rende et bien merci
c'est adorable voilà donc je tenais à
vous
faire part de toute ma gratitude à vous
souhaiter d'excellentes fêtes de fin
d'année profitez-en bien vous n'y avait
pas trop fait pas mal au bide mais
franchement pour profiter de ces petits
moments là il faut savoir les saisir
je vous embrasse et je vous dis à très
bientôt
[Musique]
hoarau
nous avons testé